my content is pretty happy and I'm a
happy dude and what's that do you know
what's funny
negative negativity is a lot easier to
sell that's why it's working like what I
do for a living is much harder I'm
trying to win on positivity which is the
hardest sell you're either on offense or
you're not like to me dwelling is super
not interesting it's got zero value I
just buy dope you need to be thoughtful
you need to understand you need to not
have too much ego to lack the humility
that why did we get here
but dwelling it I'm not interested in
dwelling of what just happened in our
countries I'm willing to like I'm
interested in like being on the offense
to a start closing the gap back to the
social I care about the social impacts I
sent an email to the entire company
tonight of an emoji heart knows it or
not I think I wrote something like I
love you or something but the emails
that I got back were so insane like just
like people like really needed it like
people like it so it takes so little to
do Slyke it's so easy to say hey like or
wink at somebody or just smile but it's
not because you actually have to believe
it and people don't actually believe it